et bien voici un auteur compositeur que
vous aimez tous beaucoup
il essaie de s'amuser avec les tempos
les styles de chansons
selon ces impulsions ses chansons sont
syncopé comme le loir et cher ou tendres
comme celle ci qui s'appelle fais abb
pour la première fois la télévision
cette chanson voici michel delpech
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la lumière revient déjà le film est
terminé
je rêvais
[Musique]
c'est bien je rôde il ya une petite
erreur de nos amis du son va leur
demander maintenant de préparer la
banque que michel delpech de chanter
l'hymne nouvelles chansons mais pas que
je chante quelques noms mais non mais
non mais il vaut mieux avancer encore
j'aime beaucoup mieux mais je rappelle à
nos amis du son que la chanson à paris
on va refaire l'entrée d'après la
chanson s'appelle dézinguer ce graphe
elle est toute nouvelle il n'a jamais
chanté à la télévision le disque va
sortir très très bientôt dès que vous
êtes prêt vous nous faites signe pas
aujourd'hui non plus bailleurs il
achoppe je pense qu'ils valent que tout
de même finir par la chambre et parce
qu'il l'a répété hier et que ça se
présentait très habile mais lorsqu'une
émission directe 6 comprend que je
l'aimé alors la chanson est très tendre
comme je vous dis elle change un peu du
loir et cher qui était beaucoup plus à
copé on trouve là le michel delpech du
divorce etc
vous allez voir ça s'appelle fais moi un
bébé n'ont fait un bébé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]